clear and continuing russian military
buildup in the ukrainian yet more
russian military vehicles being moved
towards ukraine any here in ukraine
worry that this could be a dress
rehearsal for some sort of invasions are
growing with potentially catastrophic
consequences to the rising fears this
morning moscow appears to be setting the
stage for an attack ross johnson has
warned vladimir putin that a russian
invasion of ukraine would be a
disastrous violence lots of its weaponry
and equipment at the border could invade
at any time the situation is certainly
critical
vladimir
[Music]
[Music]
is
at the moment when the first strikes hit
ukraine at the early days of um
24th of february
it was reminiscent of a hitler's
invasion
on the soviet union
here we go
my immediate thought was
all of the dangers that
are facing
not only ukraine but all of us
basically that the whole country just uh
saw that unsinkable happen
we are now into completely uncharted
territory
so i woke up and i checked my phone
where it was saying put in declared war
with us
[Music]
people are super scared
because nobody knows what to do
[Music]
in the early hours of thursday morning
thousands of russian troops enter
ukraine from borders in the north south
[Music]
russians starting rolling in tanks
into ukrainian territory and doing
precision strikes at that time on
airports
on
military bases of ukrainian soldiers
these air sirens uh warning citizens
about airstrikes
especially in haki that was the first
city of intense assault
as russian tanks continue to cross into
the country world leaders start to ask
what are putin's intentions
the russian objective will be to get
into kiev and remove that regime kiev is
the political center of gravity it's
it's where president zielenski and the
government operate from so it is the
political key to this war
they tried to do it the way western
forces would have done it with quite
fast-moving relatively light armored
forces moving moving quickly using air
power using modern technology and cyber
security um and
grabbing the ukrainian government in
kiev and affecting regime check
we
everybody who is saying are we afraid of
this third world war well i have a
surprise for you
it already started
the ukrainian people now begin to flee
the country in their thousands
[Music]
we went by car like three
uh three days
and we stepped in a car
because we couldn't find
the place where to sleep
so we stepped
[Music]
[Music]
life-changing decisions are made in an
instant
husbands and fathers staying to fight
as women and children escaped
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
those who can't get out are forced
underground
foreign
a country which only days earlier was
largely at peace now in turmoil because
of one man
the most important thing to remember
about putin is that he is the kgb
operative he comes from the russian
tradition of security services
members of the kgb were trained to
regard themselves as
the last
bastion of
soviet power
he has a reputation
cultivated but credible
of being a street fighter
who
understands
that his credibility rests on carrying
through his threats
putin's career in the kgb took him to
east germany where he witnessed the fall
of communism
the cold war came to an end in 1991
soviet union collapsed
all of the newly emergent east european
states wanted to join nato
i think he has a nostalgia for russia's
history a feeling that russia was once a
great country an empire if you like
in 2008 russia invaded georgia and from
then on it was clear that president
putin had a design in mind which we
didn't take very seriously of recreating
russian influence in the old soviet
space
in 2014 he took the biggest step of all
towards that
um by
invading ukraine briefly and grabbing
crimea
i think putin sees himself as the savior
of russia
i think he's got a messianic
self
belief
his sense of history is that he is going
to be the the new stalin the new peter
the great the new czar
[Music]
it's a very personalized almost like
byzantine despotic leadership
[Music]
the russian assault continues unabated
[Music]
this driver remarkably survived after
his car was hit by a russian tank
so you were asleep
[Music]
vladimir zelensky was an entertainer now
he finds himself on the world stage
zielinski is an extraordinary
figure
a comedian
a comic actor
who was condescended to
by putin
[Applause]
zelensky's ability to tell a story
becomes an irrefutable advantage to the
country
this former actor is showing leadership
and courage which can't be faked
a actor leading ukraine in a war
in a very asymmetric way very asymmetric
way towards putin that is just purely
trying to deploy its tanks and um
ballistic missiles into ukraine where
zelensky for example speaks directly to
people
he was called by
president biden and offered a ticket to
leave kiev
to see the president of that country
stand up and say i don't need
transportation i need arms
that is
a quote that will be in history
as a brave leader who is staying with
his people
he constantly boosts the morale of the
ukrainian people especially after rumors
fly around the country that he's fled or
worse
leaders
his strategic value is that he has
turned the international community
against russia on terms that president
putin would never have conceived as
possible
as the situation intensifies the
government appeals for help
the head of our administration came and
said
we think we will be giving away uh guns
and i said okay uh
like sign me in for 20. and so then my
fellow
politicians and i we went to get the
guns
and it was so surreal you cannot even
imagine
at first
we were scared really scared
but now
we are ready to fight
and like fights like hell
i think many ukrainians didn't need much
galvanizing to reject a russian invasion
[Music]
always knew that ukraine
would resist
it was clear from
2014 because yes putin took over crimea
rather easily but there was resistance
in the rest part of ukraine
72 hours in kiev holds on unexpectedly
it feels like this won't be the quick
invasion putin expected
the russians hoped and thought that they
could simply drive in with light forces
and take the surrender they found in the
face of
enormous opposition from the ukrainian
people they're not going to do that and
the issue we're now confronting is how
much of kiev are they going to have to
destroy
and how much of the population are they
going to have to kill to get to
president
[Music]
stop fascist russia stop fasting
[Music]
[Music]
there is a unity
amongst
many many countries
apple has halted all product sales in
russia they are suspending all russian
teams
they understand the dangers of putin
regime for
europe all together
very profound anti-russian satan
sentiments all over the world ukraine
[Music]
president silency is a natural
communicator he has turned the
international community against russia
on terms that president putin would
never have conceived as possible ukraine
for the first time ever the european
union will finance the purchase and
delivery of weapons and other equipment
to a country that is under attack
this is a watershed moment
[Music]
as the world stands up to putin his
forces continue to give much of ukraine
a pounding
a menacing 40-mile convoy heads towards
the capital
[Music]
but its progress is slow
putin's plan seems to be stalling
their logistics have failed so they're
running out of fuel and food and the mud
means that large bits of equipment are
stuck and holding up the entire convoy
the ukrainians are resisting
and russian armed forces are not doing
as well
do not have as higher morale as
had been expected
so now they've gone back to plan a which
is what they normally understand which
is a ground offensive which moves
relatively slowly surrounds the cities
and pounds them to
submission
he's already facing this humiliation on
the battlefield
[Music]
because he honestly saw that he'll take
ukraine in 100
hours or what did he say two three days
my tanks will be in kiev
he's got a limited number of options if
he's backed into a corner he can cut off
the energy supplies to europe he can
spread
chaos
elsewhere
or he can
threaten or actually go
nuclear terrified absolutely
because
they have raised the alert status
of
some of their nuclear weapons
in russia and the argument they're
they're giving is that that's in
response
to rhetoric coming out of nato
so they're not
positioning what they're saying as being
offensive they're saying it's a
defensive move i think we have to take
it extremely extremely seriously
and i am sure absolutely sure from
having
sat around the nato table
that every single nato minister is
taking it seriously
with the possibility of literally going
nuclear many began to question putin's
sanity
in recent weeks russia's leader seemed
increasingly isolated his behavior more
erratic
[Music]
people who have known mr putin over the
years
in the west
say that the person that they knew in
2003 2010 2012
was a
a rational well-briefed cool thinking
aggressive leader putin you can call him
cynical you can call him
you know
irresponsible but he has always been
quite rational
in his actions today it is much harder
there are suggestions he's become
increasingly paranoid spending much of
the pandemic isolated
his worldview seems to have become
smaller along with his inner circle
how sane a person can be with so much
power and so little uh diversity of
opinion around his table who knows if
he's afraid of corvidor and
assassination attempt when he sits well
apart from people
it's
again part of this uh syndrome of
thinking
that only he can save russia
andre kortenov has been a kremlin
advisor but even he is now questioning
the sanity of this war
[Music]
it's very embarrassing
for all of us not only because we turned
out to be wrong but
also because
all russians will be in a difficult
position
is it evil
i have no idea whether mr putin is evil
or not
but what he embraces
is clearly
evil in the way it is carried out there
is a complete lack of personal
compassion
for the forces that he unleashes
[Music]
russia has attacked the tv tower in the
capital kiev the problem for us in
understanding
what's going on in russia
is that most people get their news
and have their opinions formed
through the television channels and one
of the priorities for putin
as soon as he became president in 2000
was to control
as putin tells russia his operation in
ukraine is going to plan
state tv reinforces the message
[Music]
we don't know how long it will take for
the
the the truth of what's really happening
in ukraine to filter back into russia
but undoubtedly one of the reasons that
the russians have found it hard going is
that their conscripts are completely
unprepared for what they've met and that
the army seems to have been told that
you'll be welcomed as liberators not as
occupiers
it even appears that the russian troops
themselves are misinformed at the u.n
the ukrainian ambassador reads an
unverified text message from a conscript
back to his mother
[Music]
foreign
but tensions do rise back in russia as
small pockets of protests break out
russia is now under such heavy economic
sanctions
that uh it the economy will be crippled
uh its population is already you know
quite dissatisfied and this is just the
beginning of it the uk is announcing the
largest and most severe package of
economic sanctions that russia has ever
seen we've now sanctioned russian banks
that together hold around one trillion
dollars in assets
we're seeing the true value of
harnessing the private sector in ways
that really do tell so sport culture
banking
law insurance all of those things visa
and mastercard are suspending operation
ikea the furniture straw has said it is
closing its 17 stores mcdonald's has
said it is going to be pausing its
operations in russia the sanctions
themselves
can be incredibly important
in turning the tide of this situation
and making russia think again
[Music]
russia has been made a pariah amongst
the international community
but is the west doing enough to help
ukraine
western
foreign policy in general is always
caught between
the emotion of human rights
and
a more
sober more brutal clear-eyed judgment
about
national security interests
are dying please we are brave nation but
we need help we need support i hope the
funds will get there no fly zone well
and i'm sure that we'll get it at some
point because otherwise we'll lose the
war
establishing a no-fly zone would mean
that we would have to
watch
and monitor
and if violated give warning and then
shoot down whatever
aircraft is violating that no-fly zone
because if you do shoot down a soviet
aircraft then that we're in the war
ukraine
will try to get
as much closer to europe as is a
strategic objective so for example
pushing for eu membership
zielinski
in my view has emerged as the man of the
21st century
he has created enormous change by his
courage
we are seeing a gleaming example of
someone who's very effective in in using
all forms of media to get his message
across to his own people and
internationally zelensky might be
rallying the world but the ukrainian
people want only one question answered
when will this end i think it is almost
inevitable
that there will be at least months of
civil resistance to russian forces
i know that ukraine first of all will
not surrender the way uh putin imagined
in his his mind
uh and i see
a mobilization on this horizontal level
ukrainians helping each other
this is invincible
everyone is so bonded with ukraine and
everyone wants this to work out for them
to have a country
to which to return
and
[Music]
hope that their resilience and their
spirit will not die
now of course you know i'm depressed i
think many of us are depressed i think
that there are many people in the
kremlin who should be depressed we can
talk about
the collateral damage about sanctions
about many things
but the grim reality is that
[Music]
there are losses of human life
i should definitely say that the bravery
of ukrainians changed ukraine and
changed the world
our security does not come for free
and i think ukraine demonstrates that
it's worth dying for this
i think this is the wall that has
changed the world europe has
rediscovered itself in less than two
weeks and it's reminded us
that the prosperity and freedoms of
europe
can't be taken for granted
[Music]
so
[Music]
you